Tara Smith: In some cases,
people do infect themselves.
Hi, I'm Tara Smith.
I'm a professor of epidemiology
at Kent State University in Ohio.
I study infectious diseases
and have long been interested
in zombie infections.
So, today, we'll be talking
about zombies in movies
and rating them for realism.
Edwin: It invades the
brain like meningitis.
The adrenal glands hemorrhage.
The brain goes into shutdown.
Two hours, one minute.
Smith: So, this one is mixed.
So, it does have an incubation period.
It usually takes several days
between the time that
one is exposed to a virus
and one develops symptoms.
Lori: It restarts the brain?
Edwin: No, just the brain stem.
Smith: Viruses can get into the brain.
He mentions meningitis,
which is actually about
kind of the outside covering of the brain,
and then you would say encephalitis
when it actually goes into
the deeper parts of the brain.
So that can happen. There are viruses
that cause those type of illnesses.
But, you know, once
you're dead, you're dead.
And even if this
reanimated the brain stem,
that still wouldn't quite make sense
because you wouldn't be able to walk.
You could breathe, your heart would beat,
but you wouldn't be actively going out,
you know, shambling around.
But that anyone who died
would also become a zombie,
even if they died in other mechanisms.
So, that's a little less realistic.
I mean, yellow fever is one that
people can get very
ill, be close to death,
and then sometimes they
come back and feel fine
and then are dead the next day.
So it has what we call a biphasic illness.
It has different phases.
And, of course, back in the day,
before people had stethoscopes
and things like that,
if you had somebody who, again,
was very ill with some infection,
you listen for a heartbeat
or try to feel for a pulse.
It might be very weak.
It might not be detectable
to the average person.
And so there are lots of stories
from outbreaks of the bubonic plague,
outbreaks of cholera,
and even also yellow fever
and other types of infections
where people have been
taken out of their homes,
put in the dead cart,
going off to be hauled to the graveyard,
and they wake up in the cart.
You know, the human body
decomposes rather quickly.
So it starts out really from the inside
that you have all these
bacteria in your gut,
in your mouth, on your
skin, that, once you die,
you become a big food source for them.
So they're the ones that do a lot
of the initial decomposing.
And there's nothing about
this particular virus
that would stop that.
They have these shamblers that
have taken years and years
that are still walking
around after the outbreak,
and they would all just
be bones by that time.
Something would have eaten them,
whether it would be the
bacteria that they carry
or other rats or scavengers
or something like that.
Yeah, again, it gets a bump
for the incubation period,
but downgraded for the reanimation,
so maybe a five.
I mean, as a lab scientist,
[laughs] it makes me cringe.
But you could see that the
virus is liquid on the floor,
and it would not be aerosolized like that.
So, there would be maybe
a little bit of a splash
in the immediate vicinity,
but there's nothing that is making
that liquid become airborne.
But he's in the blue suit with
the helmets and everything,
so obviously this is a lab
that studies things that are dangerous.
You wouldn't have ventilation
go into the rest of the building.
What you would have would be filters
in the ventilation system
that have very small pores
so they can trap even viruses
from getting out of the building.
And then that ventilation
usually goes out to fresh air,
so to outside rather
than inside the building.
So even if there was a few viral
particles that made it out,
they would be diluted
when they made it outside
to the fresh air and
not a danger to anyone.
That also would completely not happen,
even in my laboratory.
No food, no drink in the
laboratory, anything at all.
[dog sniffing]
[dog barking]
There are some animals
that have been trained
to detect certain pathogens.
So, not necessarily like how they are in,
how they would be in the room air here,
but sometimes dogs,
or sometimes they've used pouched rats
that can be trained to diagnose people
who are infected, like, with
tuberculosis, for example.
So they're using more of the chemicals
that humans put off when they're infected,
rather than directly smelling, like,
the tuberculosis bacterium.
Yeah, this is about a one. [laughs]
Doctor: He's gonna inject himself.
Segen: We have no idea
which one's gonna work.
[zombie moaning]
[teeth chattering]
Smith: So, they had noticed
previously in the movie
that people who are sick
are avoided by zombies.
So Pitt is trying to inject
himself with something
to basically make the zombies ignore him
and believe that he is sick so
they don't want to bite him.
Of course, we're not trying to
hide from predators like this
when we're ill, but there are examples
where we can use microbes to
kind of fight off each other.
Back before antibiotics were common
for treatment of infections,
they actually used injection with malaria,
a parasite that causes high fevers,
as an attempt to treat
syphilis, a bacterial infection,
and that actually won
a Nobel Prize in 1927.
Today, we don't use it anymore
because we do have antibiotics.
So, what we do use sometimes
are viruses called bacteriophage
that can actually kill bacteria
that may be resistant
to the drugs we have,
but not quite in the way it's
described in "World War Z."
In some cases, people
do infect themselves.
Probably the most famous of
those was Dr. Barry Marshall.
He was an Australian scientist
who won the Nobel Prize, again,
for discovering that a bacterium
called Helicobacter pylori
causes, first, gastric ulcers.
People didn't necessarily believe him,
so he ended up swallowing a mixture
of Helicobacter pylori himself
and then treated himself with antibiotics.
Maybe about a three. [laughs]
I think the book was much
better as far as realism,
but the movie took the concept
and I think twisted it a little bit.
Scientist: The chimps are infected!
Activist: Infected with what?
Scientist: Rage.
[chimpanzees hollering]
[men screaming]
[chimps screaming]
[blood splatters]
Activist: [screams] Oh, my God!
[woman gagging]
[man screaming]
Smith: The incubation period
is basically instantaneous.
When blood goes all over,
that is how some blood-borne
diseases can be transmitted.
For example, Ebola is a disease
that is transmitted by exposure to blood
and other body fluids.
In this case, potentially
even if people aren't bitten,
if that blood goes into their
eyes or other mucus membranes,
they could be infected that way as well.
So that part could happen.
But, again, the incubation
period would take days for this.
In animals, at least, rabies
does cause a lot of aggression.
In humans, a little bit less.
It does cause depression.
It does cause active biting,
because in rabies it's transmitted
through saliva, as well.
So, not too surprising
that a virus called rage
could have those similar
kind of aggressive, biting.
[man screaming]
[dramatic music]
Smith: Yeah, so some viruses
do cause eye infections,
so basically a form of conjunctivitis.
In this case, it's infecting usually
a different place of the eye
that you don't typically see with viruses.
Again, we see that with Ebola.
We've seen that a little bit
with the current coronavirus also,
that some people do seem
to have eye infections
from that as well.
So, there are carrier states
for various types of organisms.
You don't see it as often in viruses,
but you do have things like HIV
that people can have chronic infection
and be infected for a long time
and transmit the virus to others.
So, we actually do see that occasionally
with blood-borne pathogens,
like not only HIV,
but hepatitis B virus
and hepatitis C virus.
And they do try to incorporate
some of those aspects
of the biology of the virus.
So I'd say this one's
maybe a six or a seven.
Columbus: It's been two
months since patient zero
took a bite of a contaminated
burger at a Gas N' Gulp.
Just two months, and I might be the last
non-cannibal freak in the country.
Smith: This is another one
that is not a viral infection.
When we're talking about mad cow disease,
that's actually caused by
what, we call it a prion,
so an infectious protein.
One of the things about those
is they often are ingested.
That's why the big scare
in the UK many years ago,
some cows infected with this
may have gotten into the food chain,
people may have eaten it,
and potentially could
develop disease that way.
But that two-month time frame
would not be realistic at all.
This is a condition that
takes many years to develop,
'cause what happens is
that you ingest the prion
and it ends up in your brain eventually.
And what it does is that all
of the proteins in your body
have to be folded a certain way, OK?
So they have, you know, a
long amino acid sequence,
but that's just the first part.
Those amino acids have
to not only come together
one after another in the right way,
but also they have to have
what we call a tertiary structure,
so a three-dimensional structure
that has to be a certain way
in order for the protein
to function correctly.
And so what this prion does
is that not only is it folded incorrectly,
but as it gets into your brain,
it basically acts as a template
for other proteins in your brain
and causes them to misfold.
And so as those proteins increasingly
are misfolded in your brain,
it causes little sections
of your brain to die.
So it causes what's called
a spongiform encephalopathy.
So that's the official
name for mad cow disease,
is bovine spongiform encephalopathy,
and it basically leads your brain
to become Swiss cheese over time.
It can take decades,
so the timeframe is pretty off here.
Coming back from the dead is, as well.
[Columbus screaming]
[zombies growling]
It can definitely cause
behavioral changes,
you know, aggression or things like that.
Although to the level of chasing people
and trying to eat them,
I don't think that's ever been established
with any kind of prion disease.
I would give this one also maybe a five.
Firefighter: We can't help you.
We can't help you unless you calm down.
An ambulance is on its way
right now, all right?
Woman: No! [screams]
[medic screaming]
[blood squelching]
Smith: Yeah, so this is
kind of similar to, again,
that rabies aspect of it.
Rabies is probably the only
other virus that we know
that is basically 100% fatal.
There have been a couple of
people who were infected.
You can get what's called
postexposure prophylaxis.
So if you have not gotten
the rabies vaccine before
and you've been exposed,
you've had a bite from a rabid dog
or a wild animal or exposed to a bat,
you can get the rabies vaccine
shortly after your exposure.
That can basically stop the virus
from replicating in your body,
so that will protect you from infection.
But rabies has a very
long incubation period,
you know, weeks to
sometimes months or more.
So once you have symptoms of rabies,
basically it is completely 100% fatal.
Police: You need to
remain in the building!
Smith: I mean, you would have
to get public health involved
really quickly, 'cause
they're the ones really
with the authority to shut anything down.
So, presumably somebody would call 911,
call police, call an ambulance,
and it would go from the
hospital first responders
to the public-health
department, who would say,
"OK, we have some kind
of an outbreak here."
We would quarantine everyone.
So that would be a pretty rapid response.
Yeah, I would give this, again,
maybe, like, a three.
[stroller wheels creaking]
[zombie growls]
[gun bangs]
[zombie grunts]
There are some fungal infections
that can affect the brain,
but they don't seem to cause
the type of behavioral changes like this.
Dr. Caroline: The next stage
in the fungus' life cycle,
the mature sexual stage.
This is a sporangium, a seed pod.
If they were to open...
Sgt. Eddie: What?
Dr. Caroline: The end of the world.
Smith: You know, this is
modeled on insect pathogens,
where the fungus infects the insect,
and it does change its behavior.
They basically force the insects
to go as high as they can up a tree,
and eventually, the
fungus causes the insect
to just basically be a host
for kind of that next phase of evolution.
They talk about it in there.
But basically you have this fruiting body
that will replicate in the insect
and then kind of pop out
somewhere of their body,
from their head or elsewhere.
And then that is what sporulates.
And so, when it sporulates,
it releases all of the new fungi,
and then they kind of rain down
over the colony of insects
and can infect all of those.
So that's how it ends up amplifying.
We have had fungal infections
that have gone around the
world or around a country.
So, I live in an area in northeast Ohio
that used to be covered by chestnuts,
but then they all got a fungal disease
and they basically all died.
This can happen. Those can be transported
very easily through the air.
So that's kind of the premise of this,
that if something was adapted to humans
that was like this cordyceps
that infects insects,
that this could be the result.
I believe in The Last of Us
they have a lot of
different kind of phenotypes
or different types of zombies
that kind of evolve over
the course of infection.
Yeah, I would say,
I would give this a six.
Prisoner: No!
Guard: They don't look
like volunteers to me.
Scientist: Millions of people
are dying for no reason.
These men are gonna die
to help us find a vaccine.
Smith: So, I love this show.
I think "Z Nation" is
completely underrated
as far as zombie shows go.
So, some things that are at
least somewhat accurate here
is that we do have a long history, one,
of doing experiments on prisoners.
For many years, if you
needed something done,
you went to prisons and
you went to orphanages,
because they were places
where you could get consent rather easily.
Whether this is being done legally or not,
it would be actually very difficult
to do these experiments
on prisoners right now
because there's so many issues of consent.
So that is actually kind of accurate,
although hopefully not anymore.
So, you have Murphy, who was
injected with this serum.
Of course, he gets
bitten and doesn't turn.
So, throughout the show,
he's kind of not only
resistant to the virus
but able to control other zombies,
which, again, may not be very realistic.
But you do have people with perhaps
kind of partial immunity to
some of these infections.
Murphy: Eight times
I was bitten,
and did not turn!
Eight times I was infected
by their bloody saliva!
Smith: Sometimes, vaccine
protection is complete.
Sometimes it's incomplete.
That's actually what we are expecting
for the coronavirus vaccine,
that we don't expect it
will be 100% effective.
But this is kind of what we
see for the influenza vaccine,
that it protects people from infection,
but not all of the time.
But even for people who are
vaccinated, get influenza,
you tend to have more mild symptoms,
so kind of what Murphy is seeing here.
Yeah, probably about a two.
It's pretty unrealistic,
especially some of the
scenarios they get into later on.
[dramatic music]
[water splashing]
[man yells]
David: It was a big plane, Russ.
Russ: Why's that?
David: 'Cause we're right on top of it.
Smith: If you're transporting
a very deadly bioweapon,
it would likely be in very tight storage,
multiple layers probably,
and you'd also have dry ice
or something to keep it cold.
So exactly how it was released
during this plane crash
is not very clear, I think.
That water supply, the
virus would be diluted,
and even further so as it got spread out
to all the people of the town.
So you'd have to have a really small
infectious dose for this,
like one virus for people to get infected.
And then, most likely the virus
would be killed off in the water,
because rabies is a virus
that needs a host to amplify.
It's not typically a waterborne virus.
So it's unclear exactly
how that would happen,
how it would survive in that water
in order to infect those.
If you don't have that knowledge
that a government plane went down
carrying a bioweapon there
and you're just doing this
based on the symptoms,
it would take a lot to
kind of tie those together.
Usually when we see outbreaks
of waterborne disease,
we respond to them,
because you have upticks
in people reporting to their doctors
with gastrointestinal symptoms,
with diarrhea and vomiting.
One of the biggest-ever outbreaks
of waterborne disease in the
United States in modern times
was in Milwaukee in 1993.
They had an outbreak of a
parasite called cryptosporidium.
And one of the early indicators for that
was that all of the Imodium
was gone from stores.
People weren't necessarily
reporting to their doctor
that they had diarrhea,
but they were going out
for anti-diarrheal medicine.
I'll put this down at
about a two. [laughs]
[Kay screaming]
Andy: Oh, no. [grumbling]
[Andy groaning]
[bite squelching]
[Andy screams]
Smith: While he's in
that incubation period,
know that he is going to turn eventually.
And so this idea of bringing
back pathogens from history
as you're digging into the ground,
as the permafrost thaws,
can some of these pathogens
that have been locked in ice
cores for millennia or longer,
could those come back?
Yes, some of them definitely can.
Anthrax has caused outbreaks
in some areas of Siberia.
One thing is that anthrax is
a really hearty bacterium.
It forms spores, so it's really
stable in the environment.
But again, we don't know
how long those would last.
If it's decades or centuries
or longer, we're not sure.
But I do want to kind of
put a flip side to this,
is that when scientists
were trying to study
the 1918 flu virus, so the one that caused
the last big global pandemic,
they found some samples from this
that were frozen in permafrost,
so one in Alaska and
one in northern Europe.
In Alaska in the 1950s,
scientists went up there,
dug up some of the people who had died
and who were, again,
preserved in permafrost for many years,
took samples of their lungs,
tried to grow them in the laboratory,
completely unsuccessful.
There was no live virus there.
Did the same thing with
some of the samples
from, again, northern Europe,
just about 15 years ago or so.
So we were able to get
viral RNA from those,
and that's actually one of
the reasons we know so much
about the sequence of the 1918 flu virus,
but could not grow it at all.
And so most viruses are more fragile
than, like, bacteria,
so a viral outbreak would
probably be less likely
from something that has
been long put in the ground.
[fire crackling]
[crickets chirping]
Cleverman: They're poisoning
this land, you know?
This country's changing.
Sick, we all get sick.
Smith: Interrupting nature,
that's a big problem.
In West Africa, we had the Ebola outbreak
a couple years ago, the really big one,
and part of that may have been
from the more frequent
introductions of the virus
into the human population
across parts of Africa
where they're being deforested.
Now the bats are all in close contact
and they're in closer contact
with other animals in the forest
because there's only this
little part of it left.
So there's more potential for transmission
for that virus to other animals.
People eat those other animals.
People come in contact with that
through butchering them
or other types of things.
And so it can jump into humans.
So we see that cycle on and on.
So maybe at a four.
I like "28 Days Later" just
'cause it really scares me.
I can suspend disbelief
for all of the science
that's maybe exaggerated or
kind of mistold in there,
but the story just really freaks me out.